things are about to get a little messy I
do wrong work no time for weakness whoa
fantastic oh my god open your eyes hi
I'm Alvin I'm a tasty producer and I
love making giant this season on tasty
is making a big I'm going to be making
giant food for friends people that I
admire and people that I've always
wanted to meet I've always admired
competitive eaters and today I've
invited Ryan uh Wong a competitive eater
who also does amazing food challenges on
her Channel
let's go meet her and see what kind of
[ __ ] wants me to make how's it going
nice to meet you how did you start to
get into competitive eating my
first-ever food challenge without any
kind of practice was a four pound
burrito and then I managed to finish
that in six minutes four pound burrito
how large was that it was like this but
it was fat oh my god that is crazy is
that you're most proud eating
accomplishment I actually had the
workout in and out
wait really yeah I have I ate a 50 by 50
in one city it is 50 patties and 50
slices of cheese so it was literally
like this long I want to make a giant
food challenge for you today obviously
you've eaten a lot of crazy thing but if
you were to pick one food for me to make
for you what do you think could be fun
um you know what I've actually done a
lot of food challenges but I never seen
giant chicken nuggets or a giant fries I
did a chicken nugget challenge okay
hundred chicken nuggets in four minutes
but not a huge one okay well sounds like
I have a pretty big task ahead of me I
want to see if I can make something that
you know will stand up to your athletic
prowess so I might be a couple hours but
I hope you're hungry I am all right cool
I'll go to the kitchen
the giant chicken nuggets and giant
fries they're not the newest thing some
popular YouTube channels have done them
already but we're gonna do our own
version and see where it takes us
I think it'll be nice to freshly grind
some chickens so we have boneless
skinless chicken thighs this is 7 pounds
sounds like a lot that's because it is
you know we're gonna do these in batches
because I don't think I'll be able to
grind all this chicken at the same time
here goes nothing
that's what I like to see in the morning
may or may not look gross to you but
ever had a hot dog a burger or a sausage
it's basically the same thing I'm also
using chicken thighs
I like the thighs over breasts because
the thighs are juicier there's more fat
I think that'll add a lot more flavor to
the final chicken nugget one last grind
here we go and it's not working what'd I
do wrong work oh the top goes pop goes
that way this is why you stay in school
kids mmm delicious
so this is seven pounds of ground
chicken I'm going to season it because
you always have to season your meat so
we have some salt coarsely ground black
pepper garlic powder some onion powder
so nothing too crazy to give this a nice
old mix here so this is our chicken
mixture seized them nicely and now we
are going to shape it into chicken
nugget chips things are about to get a
little messy oh boy this is appetizing
fast food nuggets they have four
different shapes a bell a bone a boot
and a ball I'm just gonna start with the
easiest first I'm just gonna make a ball
any DJ's out there public a remix that
[Music]
it's what they call a slapper I want to
say that's that's the ball shape we're
gonna make three more so I'm gonna grind
twenty-one pounds more and we're gonna
make three other shapes yes
our second shape is the bell it's kind
of like an egg I want to say that's the
bell the bone has got like this kind of
weird little thing sticking out it's got
a peninsula that's a word I learned in
geography class this is apparently the
bone last one we got the boot it just
basically look like the bone and then
there's someone like Photoshop has
stretched it out a little bit don't
think I'll wear this boot cuz this
chicken I would say this is pretty much
done I'll put these in the oven and I'll
see you in a bit okay so while the
chicken is baking in the oven I'm gonna
start making from the fries my initial
idea was to fry just one whole potato
but then I was like it's not big enough
Alvin come on what are you doing it's
not the name of the show we're gonna go
for something a lot bigger
it starts with five pounds of potatoes
so this is going to boil until they
really fork tender and cooked it's a lot
of potatoes it might take a while so see
you guys in probably ten years whenever
this water decides to boil I'm gonna go
take a nap now it's a good nap see how
these potatoes are doing okay these look
pretty cooked a little more appetizing
in the chicken God do a little Q C okay
Idaho I found a really cool toy in the
back that we're gonna use to mash these
this is really awesome look at this guy
gonna throw some potatoes in here and
see if this actually works
oh okay it is official I like this toy
let's load this up with some more
potatoes here we go
that's like G's coming out holy moly
just like in the club make it ready I
don't think this is structurally stable
enough to make the fries so I'm gonna
put in some corn starch season with some
salt to taste we're just gonna give it a
nice mix the consistency is like normal
mashed potatoes it's kind of like that
feeling if you've ever made like instant
mashed potatoes but it's a little bit
more crumbly I don't want this to be wet
if it's wet it goes in the fryer that's
just bad oil and water are like
arch-nemesis you know they just fight
it's that shot you know when the super
hero and the super villain they both do
their ultimate move and it meets in the
middle and the whole world blows up kind
of want to avoid that happening I got
the biggest tray we could find in the
tasty kitchen we're gonna make in shape
some fries
I'm gonna be generous and say this
entire mixture makes about like four
fries or so so I think I can just shape
these into a nice long french fries
shape this is an ancient technique swim
to pass down for generations the
fast-food industry would kill for these
secrets that's actually looking pretty
good I would say and I got my trusty
tools to help me get these really
straight I think that's one good look at
a fry this little smooth pat down on the
top oh I shave I gave him my haircut
last one the Big Daddy the head honcho
oh there you have it five pounds of
potatoes four fries not bad think I'm
gonna go make another four cuz you don't
just eat for fries come on eat like
20,000 I'm gonna put these in the
freezer and I'm gonna check on the
chicken to see how they look and I'm
gonna go wash my hands because there's
potatoes everywhere
look at these bad boys right here oh my
god I think my favorite honestly is
going to be this boot before I said this
is a boot that I don't think anybody
would wear I've changed my mind
I will rock these any day of the week I
want to make a batter I don't want to
make a dry dredge when you have them at
the fast-food restaurants they're crispy
they're light the airy I think those are
the signs of a liquid batter they also
have a very large Hotel pan to make this
batter in because this nugget will not
fit normal pan all right first thing you
got some flour cornstarch sugar baking
powder then for some seasoning and
spices we have some paprika probably one
of my favorite spices ginger ground
dried ginger some allspice and some
white pepper all right I just got some
white pepper in my mouth
Oh what if my nose too it's like kind of
stinging whenever I apply a remote
technique not the most efficient but
saves you from a lot of pain okay that
settled for eggs
boop-boo-boo-boop and then just some
good old h2o keep in mind this is for
one chicken nugget over here for quite a
while this is a really thick batter it's
gonna give it a nice crust it's just
very hard to waste one Ellen I'll make
this time there's no time for weakness
okay well batter smooth now it's time to
head into the kitchen heat up some oil
and do some really dangerous things
maybe I should not have said that
so we are in the commercial kitchen at
tasty we have a very large pot of oil
that is very hot please do not try this
at home but we have some fries to fry
and we have some chicken nuggets and
some batter to fry I want to try it with
the fries first to see how it goes to be
very careful with how I do this here
goes nothing we're gonna get one of
these really big spiders and just to
make sure that this doesn't stick oh I
hate a chunk off I won't touch it this
oil is currently at 375 which is hotter
than the normal 350 because it just
helps get a harder crust whoa oh you did
it yo this is looking fantastic oh my
god I'm gonna call it I think this is
done so I'm gonna take it out I want to
do this like seven four times and then
we're gonna fry some nuggets after that
I think this is actually the most
nerve-wracking part is this big giant
chicken nugget I have the batter here
right next to the oil so it doesn't need
to go that far when I attempt to get
this in the oil as safe as I can so
first we're gonna put on some gloves
gonna get this guy into the batter
OOP this little bath you got there Bob I
named this guy Bob well that's a thick
batter okay
it's gonna be a little tricky cuz he's
so heavy come on Bob all right we're
gonna go slow here we go whoo there it
is and we got a air bubble not the
smoothest landing it's kind of mad right
now Bob's pissed I put him in 400
degrees
he's fighting so we're gonna let him
hang out oh okay it's getting crispy
already yeah that's a really lucky
chicken nugget crust if you like you
know made me stand 300 feet away and was
like what does this look like I'll be
like that's a fast-food chicken nugget
all right I'm gonna go in
that's a chicken nugget right there whoo
seven pounds of chicken ground up baked
for 35 minutes battered and fried at 400
degrees for like two minutes and now you
get a giant chicken nugget
can you hear that like oh that's crispy
right there something that is this big
that is fried you gotta let it hang out
so we're gonna go Friday three more so
I'm gonna need some coffee
whoop it's been a day I've been frying
for about three hours now but I think
the results are well worth it we got
four chicken nuggets one of every single
shape eleven fries I went a little
overboard when you get your nuggets and
fries in your fast food meal they don't
just come in an ordinary box no they
come in iconic packaging so I asked our
art department to make some really cool
packaging for our nuggets and fries and
we're gonna put them in there it's just
a four piece chicken nugget set but the
only thing is there's seven pounds of
chicken and it's nugget so you got 28
pounds of chicken nuggets on deck I
think this looks pretty cool so let's
move on to the fries there's such an
awesome box look at that got some tall
ones got some short ones we got honey
mustard and we also have the good
old-fashioned ketchup okay so I want to
get these over to RINO because I think
she's hungry and I want to see how much
she wants to eat Ryan are you hungry oh
yeah very hung all right well I have
your food can you close your eyes yeah
oh boy this is heavy
oh that smells like the chicken on the
count of three one two three open your
eyes oh my god oh you know he's a
four-piece meal for you oh thank you and
a couple of fries over there I hope this
is a big enough of a challenge for you
how do you feel
one chicken oh good I also got a
normal-sized portion of nuggets and
fries you just for comparison let's eat
all right I don't even know how to start
this go and dip it in that Wow mmm
yeah Wow I'm chicken nuggets uh how does
it compare to a normal one yeah I should
have a lot more flavor sometimes think
food challenges I go to when they make a
big quantity the quad it usually goes
down mmm this one's okay all right man
you really Kenny that's crazy I'm gonna
try this part I feel a little bit off
here whoa
uh-huh that was delicious I definitely
got through a good amount of that
chicken nugget laughing the rest home
for dinner well thanks for coming in
hopefully you can feed the family with
the rest of this oh yeah definitely more
than enough all right oh thanks whoo
it's been a crazy day a lot of meats a
lot of potatoes a lot of frying a lot of
eating Ryan uh she can eat a lot that
was crazy to witness in person you want
to take a guess at what I'm gonna make
next week send me a message on Instagram
drop it in the comments let me know got
some crazy stuff for you guys in the
store so until next time peace
[Music]